[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zur zdf heute live
in wenigen minuten punkt 15 uhr wird sie
beginnen die bundespressekonferenz und
zwar die erste bundespressekonferenz mit
dem neuen bundesgesundheitsminister
karl lauterbach das große thema die
korona impfungen bei kindern von fünf
bis elf jahren die offizielle
impfkampagne für diese altersgruppe hat
ja in dieser woche am montag offiziell
begonnen und die nachfrage war bei den
stationen sehr sehr sehr groß 2,4
millionen impfdosen sagt die stiko
stehen zur verfügung
ja bei der bundespressekonferenz wird
der neue bundesgesundheitsminister karl
lauterbach wie sein vorgänger jens spahn
zusammen vor die presse treten mit dem
chef des robert-koch-instituts lothar
wieler dritter mit dem bunde der
direktor der klinik für kinder und
jugendmedizin an der uni köln professor
jörg butt und das hat seinen grund er
ist nicht nur in der korona
experten dem expertenrat der
bundesregierung sondern eben als kinder-
und jugendmediziner gefragt weil es
heute ganz besonders um die impfungen
bei den fünf- bis elfjährigen geht um 15
uhr werden wir also pünktlich und direkt
zu dieser pressekonferenz schalten nach
berlin wir wollen danach das gesagte
analysieren und haben dafür zwei gäste
zum einen professor reinhard berner
begrüße sie ganz herzlich sie sind
direktor der klinik und poliklinik für
kinder- und jugendmedizin in dresden und
wie hat auch im expertenrat corona
expertenrats der bundesregierung vielen
dank dass sie zeit haben
und wir haben christine
continental christiane gotte haben wir
auch dabei vorsitzende des bundes
elternrat grüße sie ganz herzlich vielen
dank dass sie auch die zeit dafür haben
grüße nach mecklenburg vorpommern
da arbeiten wir noch ein bisschen an dem
ton damit wir die frau gehören aber für
sie schon mal für alle userinnen und
user der aufruf wenn sie fragen haben
eine ganze menge fragen geben mit
sicherheit dann einfach her an uns und
wir werden sie gemeinsam mit unseren
beiden gästen besprechen und versuchen
zu beantworten ja eine sache ist
glasklar kinder wenn sie sich mit corona
infizieren haben in der regel einen
milderen verlauf nicht so einen schweren
verlauf wie ältere menschen oder
menschen mit vorerkrankungen fakt ist
aber auch dass die altersgruppe mit der
alle aller allerhöchsten corona sieben
tage incidents die gruppe der zehn bis
14 jährigen ist direkt dicht gefolgt von
den fünf bis neunjährigen das virus
breitet sich also rasant bei kindern aus
seit wochen steigen die korona zahlen
bei kindern und zwar enorm bei den zehn-
bis 14-jährigen lag die sieben tage
incident anfang oktober noch bei
175 laut letztem lka wochenbericht ist
sie nun bei über 1.000 fast genauso hoch
sind die insolvenzen bei den fünf- bis
neunjährigen dort ging es von 135 auf
951 in acht wochen
viele eltern sind nun froh dass es
endlich losgeht mit den in polen seit
anfang dieser woche wird der impfstoff
für jüngere kinder im alter von fünf bis
elf jahren gespritzt für sie stehen erst
einmal
24 millionen impfdosen zur verfügung
eine corona impfung empfiehlt die stiko
für diese altersgruppe bisher aber nur
wenn sie vorerkrankungen haben oder
risikopatienten im umfeld
herr professor werner sie haben in
dresden eine studie gemacht eine
antikörper studie bei kindern wie viele
kinder haben denn bereits antikörper so
zu und haben corona gehabt sie haben ja
sozusagen mal eine bilanz gezogen
ja diese bilanz haben wir über die
gesamte pandemie gezogen in den letzten
monaten wir waren allerdings in unseren
studien bei der gruppe der etwas älteren
kinder unterwegs also der 15-jährigen
und dort wissen wir dass nach unseren
herbst für ihn hier in sachsen die rate
der kinder die antikörper hatten etwa
bei 25 prozent lag von denen die nicht
geimpft waren
das ist ja schon extrem hoch jetzt sind
sie der experte eben was kinder angeht
was verläufe angeht wie ist denn sagen
wir mal der schweregrad des verlaufs ist
es wirklich so dass man sagen kann er
gut viele kinder infizieren sich aber es
ist fast symptomlos und wie ein
harmloser schnupfen
ja in der tat ist das so wir sehen der
viele kinder mit den corona
virusinfektionen und wir führen ja auch
hier in dresden ein bundesweites
register über die kinder mit schweren
corona virusinfektionen also für
diejenigen die ins krankenhaus müssen
und wir sehen über die gesamte partie
hinweg und auch über alle varianten
hinweg milde verläufe wenige kinder im
krankenhaus und ganz wenige kinder mit
einem schweren verlauf die auf die
intensivstation müssen also dann kann
man sagen ihre ergebnisse sind zumindest
erfreulich damit stellt sich aber eben
auch die frage impfen oder nicht impfen
ich glaube egal mit welchem vater oder
mutter man sich unterhält das ist
wirklich eine schwierige sache und jeder
hat da so seine meinung was sagen sie
denn jetzt es ist ja eine risiko nutzen
abwägung und wie sie die ihrer meinung
nach aus
ja so ist es definitiv das ist ja eine
risiko nutzen abwägung
wir wissen die krankheitsverläufe kennen
wir bei den kindern und jugendlichen wir
wissen noch relativ wenig über den
impfstoff in dieser altersgruppe das
muss man einfach sagen so dass die stiko
jahr sehr zu recht aus meiner sicht
empfohlen hat die impfung soll
angewendet werden bei kindern mit einem
risikofaktor oder vorerkrankungen oder
aber wenn familienmitglieder angehörige
da sind die ein risiko haben und selbst
vielleicht nicht geimpft werden können
eindeutig ja das ist auch hervorragend
dass für diese altersgruppe und diese
kinder diesen impfstoff gibt und dann
gibt es noch eine zweite gruppe und das
sind die kinder wo eltern sorgen haben
aus unterschiedlichen gründen und da die
stiko gesagt für diese kinder gibt es
ein impfangebot wenn der wunsch besteht
sich impfen zu lassen dann sollen sie
sich auch impfen lassen jetzt hat frau
greifen wir das auf was herr werner
gesagt hat eben die stiko das gesagt für
bei vorerkrankungen unbedingt wenn die
fünf- bis elfjährigen
gesund sind dann ist das entscheidung
der eltern man kann es machen nach einem
ärztlichen gespräch wie ist denn die
stimmung bei den eltern nach dieser
aussage der stiko ist da jetzt sozusagen
klarheit ist man zufrieden oder es da
konfusion
letztendlich kam konfusionen im vorfeld
aus als er merkels gesagt hat er würde
sein kind nicht impfen lassen das waren
moment dagegen die diskussion
tatsächlich
würde sehr sehr stark diskutiert
wir haben jetzt nach der stiko
empfehlung einfach das gefühl dass da
der druck rausgenommen wurde aus der
ganzen diskussion weil die eltern die
ein kind haben dass der wunderbare
gruppe gehört können das impfen lassen
diese familien nehmen das in beratung
des mit dem kinderarzt und in der
familie das kind sollte unbedingt
mitgenommen werden bei dieser ganzen
entscheidungsfindung der aber der
wichtigste ansprechpartner ist wie
gesagt der kinderarzt für die eltern ja
und diese eltern können sich jetzt sage
ich mal in ruhe zusammensetzen und das
mit dem kind entscheiden wir haben aber
auch die eltern die wie sie eben
erwähnten die kennen da geht nichts
dublin gruppe gehören aber vielleicht
angehörige haben die sich das auch
überlegen und die die impfungen
wahrnehmen wollen ja insgesamt hatte ich
die empfehlung mehr klarheit gebracht
druck rausgenommen weil die eltern sich
eben jetzt frei entscheiden kann und ist
wirklich in die hand der eltern und
kinderärzte gegeben wurde trotzdem gibt
es natürlich immer noch fragen und die
bekommen wir auch schon sie haben auch
gesehen wir werfen immer einen blick
auch noch auf die bundespressekonferenz
der saal ist noch relativ leer nur die
journalisten warten wir gehen wie gesagt
live rüber aber gleich direkt an sie
herr berner die frage von thomas thiele
die hier uns über facebook erreicht hat
welchen grund soll es denn geben kinder
zu impfen welchen wissenschaftlich
sachlichen grund nachdem sie jetzt auch
gerade gesagt habe in den allermeisten
fälle sind die verläufe milde
genau das ist die abwägung der stiko
gewesen sie hat sich die risikofaktoren
angeguckt und sie hat sich angeguckt die
verläufe wie viel kinder haben ein
risiko eine komplikation zu erleiden wie
viel risiko ins krankenhaus aufgenommen
zu werden auf die intensivstation
sie hat sie auch angeguckt wie ist das
risiko zu versterben und hat sich dann
an geguckt was wissen wir über die
möglichen nebenwirkungen der impfung und
ist dann zu der entscheidung gekommen es
gibt eben einzelne gruppen von kindern
da ist das risiko schwerer zu erkrankung
zu erkranken doch höher einzustufen als
das risiko der impfung was wir bisher
wissen und für diese für diese diese
kinder hat die stiko gesagt da ist es
sinnvoll eine impfung einzusetzen für
die kinder bei denen diese
risikofaktoren nicht vorlägen gibt es
und das wissen wir gut aus vielen
gesprächen große sorgen bei eltern bei
einem teil der eltern über doch
vielleicht schwerer verläufe oder die
sorge um angehörige und wenn diese sorge
überwiegt hat die stiko gesagt und so
empfehlen wir es eben auch dann sollen
diesen kindern auch der impfstoff nicht
verwehrt werden
so ich sehe mit einem auge oder wir
sehen es gemeinsam natürlich das ja
sozusagen neue gesundheits paar vorher
war es sparen wiler jetzt ist es karl
lauterbach der neue
bundesgesundheitsminister und lothar
wieler der präsident der chef des robert
koch-instituts beide haben jetzt vor in
der bundespressekonferenz
also vor den journalistinnen und
journalisten platz genommen ich werde
vermute einfach mal das nach alter
tradition ist der gesundheitsminister
hier also karl lauterbach ist der
beginnen wird zu der versammelten presse
zu sprechen
wir werden hören was er sagt was herr
wieder vom rk ii zu sagen hat herr das
haben wir hier auch noch sozusagen ein
kinderarzt die journalistin begrüßt hier
die anwesende presse und wird die
bundespressekonferenz leiten wie gesagt
hauptthema ist heute das impfen bei den
kindern von fünf bis elf jahren ich bin
mir relativ sicher es wird auch zur
sprache kommen natürlich die
impfstoffversorgung das thema was jetzt
in den letzten 48 stunden hoch gekommen
ist gibt es zu wenig impfstoff wie karl
lauterbach gesagt hat der sozusagen eine
bilanz gezogen hat geschaut hat was ist
denn da und gesagt hat im ersten quartal
2022 wird es eine impfstoff knappheit
geben das hat zu heftigen reaktionen
geführt ob man das so kommunizieren kann
ob man nicht sagen muss was man dagegen
tun will bin mir also relativ sicher
dass die kollegen die journalisten in
berlin auf dieses thema auch springen
werden das ganze auch diskutieren werden
fragen stellen werden an den
gesundheitsminister und auch an den chef
des rk ii jetzt hören wir aber ein
lauterbach zu
bedanken bevor wir zu kindern kommen und
ich bin sehr dankbar dass heute der
kollege deutsch und das kölner
universität da ist wir sind ja quasi
kollegen in der gleichen fakultät und
dass er wieder da ist
vielen dank dafür ich würde gerne das
und bevor wir dazu kommen ein paar
offene worte zu
verlieren was ist also in der nikon
krise
zu erwarten also was kommt da auf uns zu
worauf müssen wir uns einstellen ich
habe eben noch einmal mit dem britischen
gesundheitsminister david und aber auch
mit also wissenschaftlern in uk
gesprochen dort ist ja die omikron
variante schon deutlich weiter
verbreitet und ich habe nochmal ein
lagebild geben lassen habe auch noch
einmal den neueren also neuen
erkenntnisse aus den aus
epidemiologischen auswertungen
angeschaut und nach wie vor ist es so
dass eine verdopplung zeit der also
fälle im abstand von zwei bis drei tagen
stattfindet das bei einer sehr stark
durch die impften bevölkerung 85 prozent
der über zwölfjährigen und von den
geimpften sind 45 prozent bereits mit
einer booster impfung versehen das sind
sehr besorgniserregende zahlen wir sehen
in england dass also die stadt gehabt
voll impfung zwei bis drei monate nach
der zweiten impfung nur noch eine
schutzwirkung von 25 bis 40 prozent hat
und das ist das wichtigste
offenbar die booster impfung ist weil
die booster impfung erhöht diese
schutzwirkung vor symptomatische
infektionen auf 70 bis 80 prozent und
das ist gegenstand auch unsere strategie
ich hatte ja bei anderen gelegenheiten
schon also darüber gesprochen dass wir
hier an durch strategie benötigen und
die strategie der bundesregierung und
auch unseres hauses ist die dass wir
über eine sehr offensive schnelle
booster impfung strategie versuchen
werden die omikron variante so klein zu
halten wie möglich um eine überlastung
des gesundheitssystems und
möglicherweise der gesellschaft in der
gänze zu verhindern
ich hatte dazu also eine
bestandsaufnahme wenn man so will eine
inventur der aso impfstoffmengen die wir
bestellt haben und erwarten können
vorgenommen am letzten freitag ich war
mit diesen ergebnissen nicht
einverstanden weil es einfach für eine
solche booster impfung strategie nicht
raus ich habe das ihnen
ausgelegt was also da tatsächlich also
an impfstoff zu erwarten war was
impfstoff ist sehen wir geliefert
bekommen sollten und da dadurch also die
letzten drei wochen im dezember und
januar februar märz dargestellt die
situation ist die dass wir insgesamt
also im ersten quartal 50 millionen
impfstoffdosen in gemessen in booster
dosen erwarten konnten und das trifft
auf einen bedarf von 70 millionen dosen
wir brauchen also ungefähr 50 millionen
booster dosen und 20 millionen erst und
zwar dem 5000 somit ist der bedarf nicht
ganz gedeckt aber das ist noch nicht was
der wichtigste punkt sondern der
wichtigste punkt ist wenn man also mit
diesem so lieferungen die poster
kampagne macht dann ist ja einfach zu
langsam dann wäre die booster kampagne
abgeschlossen
ende märz und damit können wir nicht
arbeiten muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen
also versucht uns ausdrücklich keine
kritiker mal im vorgänger immer wieder
also werde ich konfrontiert also dass
ich damit den vorgänger kritisiere das
tue ich nicht ich habe gestern abend
auch nochmal mit wir uns sparen darüber
gesprochen wir haben halt eine sehr
offensive booster impfung strategie zu
unserem also hauptwerkzeug gemacht und
dafür braucht man sehr viel impfstoff
und dafür braucht man den impfstoff
schnell und ließen eben stoff zu
beschaffen damit habe ich begonnen jetzt
so damit hat das haus begonnen auf seine
veranlassung hin am letzten sonntag
umsätzen letzten samstag zugang sogar
wir haben da auch schon einen ersten
erfolg zu vermelden
sind im direkten kontakt mit der firma
moderne modernen stoff ist im moment
leichter zu beschaffen als biotech
impfstoff und wir haben also mit
moderner verhandelt dass wir 35
millionen dosen moderner impfstoff gerne
hätten als vorgezogene lieferung von
impfstoff den wir ohnedies in späteren
monaten des jahres hätten erwarten
können das bedarf einer zustimmung der
kommission und diese zustimmung der
kommission haben wir heute mittag
erhalten ich möchte darauf hinweisen
dass in dieser so wichtigen
verhandlungen auch olaf scholz mich
selbst aber auch unser haus sehr
intensiv auch vor ort unterstützt hat
und dafür möchte ich mich auch bei ihnen
kannst er hat sich bedanken wir werden
das dabei nicht belassen wir werden
weitermachen weil also es kann ich sagen
dass die besonders erfolgreiche poster
kampagne die wir in deutschland begonnen
habe mit 1,5 millionen booster impfungen
an einem tag gestern dass diese
ausgebremst wird weil wir nicht genug
impfstoff haben das möchten wir
verhindern
daher fand sich derzeit auch mit anderen
länder zusätzlichen impfstoff zu
bekommen so zum beispiel mit rumänien
polen portugal und auch bulgarien und
ich hoffe dass ich dann in den nächsten
tagen oder wochen ihnen da also mehr
vollzug also berichten kann wir haben
darüber hinaus eine große branche von
impfstoff
reserviert und werden wir kaufen
bei der kommission von biotech das wird
zum größten teil schon angepasster
impfstoff seien also impfstoff der auf
die omikron variante schon angepasst ist
ich hoffe dass wir von diesen 80
millionen dosen noch einen teil im
ersten quartal bekommen es kann sein
dass du den gesamten impfstoff erst also
im verlaufe des jahres nach dem ersten
quartal also katar zwei bis vier
bekommen aber diese
dieser kauf ist auch für uns von größter
bedeutung weil wir davon ausgehen dass
die booster impfung und möglicherweise
auch eine vierte impfung ihr zentrale
pfeiler einer erfolgreichen strategie
sein werden hier möchte ich mich
ausdrücklich bedanken also beim
haushaltsausschuss und auch bei also
finanzminister lindner die also die also
zur für den vollzug dieses kaufs 2,2
milliarden euro gestern im
haushaltsausschuss genehmigt haben so
dass wir da relativ gut ausgestattet
sind so viel
gemeinsam haben wir einen leichten
rückgang der fallzahlen erreicht aber
wir sind noch nicht über den berg und
tatsächlich liegen noch schwere wochen
vor uns die fallzahlen gehen zwar zurück
aber vergleichsweise langsam etwa ein
fünftel aller landkreise hat immer noch
eine inzidenz eine sieben tage in sitze
von über 500 und der rückgang ist auch
noch nicht in den kliniken und den
intensivstationen angekommen viele davon
sind seit wochen am limit
im moment dominiert in deutschland auch
die delta variante es ist aber nur eine
frage der zeit bis auch nikon übernimmt
wir rechnen damit dass sich die
situation dadurch für alle noch einmal
sehr deutlich verschärft das gilt auch
für die geimpft nikon ist noch
ansteckender als delta und wird zu noch
mehr fällen führen aber
darauf können wir uns vorbereiten wir
müssen kontakt beschränkungen und andere
maßnahmen zum schutz vor ansteckung noch
weiter intensivieren und gleichzeitig
noch schneller impfen und zwar erst
zweit und auffrischungsimpfung erstens
um zu verhindern dass sich omikron
wirklich explosionsartig verbreitet
zweitens um kliniken zu entlasten und
einen puffer zu schaffen damit wir so
gut wie möglich durch die nächsten
wochen und monate kommen im moment ist
die situation auf den intensivstationen
angespannt aber auch ohne an oregon ist
sie ja schon angesprochen es werden
weiterhin rund
4800 patienten momentan auf
intensivstationen behandelt das ist
immer noch ein sehr hohes niveau
in manchen regionen finden weiterhin
patienten verlegung statt und natürlich
werden auch weiterhin viele operationen
immer noch verschoben und jeden tag
sterben weiterhin sehr viele menschen in
verbindung mit 19 das heißt wir müssen
jetzt so schnell wie möglich von diesen
zahlen runter kommen und sie dann vor
allem auch niedrig halten die
flächendeckende kontakt beschränkungen
durch konsequentes umsetzen von
infektionen schutzmaßnahmen sie kennen
sie alle masken tragen testen lüften die
h und l regel einhalten und durch
schnelleres impfen damit die immunität
in der bevölkerung weiter gestärkt wird
all diese komponenten werden wir
weiterhin brauchen und sie parallel also
gleichzeitig einsetzen müssen gerade im
hinblick auf unicom
was wissen wir stand heute über hongkong
und was wissen wir noch nicht was wissen
wir über die übertragbarkeit in einigen
ländern breitet sich omikron bereits
sehr schnell aus zum beispiel in
großbritannien und dänemark in
deutschland sind bislang einige hundert
fälle im meldesystem übermittelt worden
aber auch hier sehen wir eine zunahme
und wir sehen fälle in jedem bundesland
was wissen wir über die wirksamkeit von
impfungen geimpft sein ist immer besser
als nicht geimpft sein das ist völlig
klar erste studien weist aber daraufhin
dass eine zweifache impfung nicht so gut
für nikon schützt oder genauer gesagt
schon drei bis vier monate nach der
zweiten impfung teilweise auch zwei
monate schon lässt der schutz vor einer
symptomatischen infektion die gute
nachricht ist aber dass dieser schutz
mit einer auffrischungsimpfung
wahrscheinlich wieder deutlich erhöht
werden kann was wir noch nicht
einschätzen können ist wie gut die
impfung vor schweren verläufen
todesfällen durch micon schützt dafür
brauchen wir weitere epidemiologische
studien wir brauchen natürlich noch
etwas zeit
was wissen über die krankheit schwerer
von omikron leider zurzeit noch nicht
viel wir können noch nicht einschätzen
ob nikon ähnlich oft schwerer verläufe
verursacht wie delta oder vielleicht
auch weniger krank macht oder mehr krank
machen was aber jetzt schon klar ist
allein dadurch dass oerlikon so extrem
ansteckend ist dass sich innerhalb eines
zeitraums noch mehr menschen infizieren
können müssen wir mit einer hohen zahl
an schweren verläufen rechnen ein aus
mathematischen gründen das bringt mich
wieder zu dem was ich am anfang sagt wir
müssen jetzt generell infektionen so gut
es geht verhindern damit sich omikron
nicht so schnell ausbreiten kann und die
kliniken entlastet werden bevor die fall
sondern wahrscheinlich wieder steigen
wir alle können die situation zu einem
großteil aber selbst durch unser
verhalten beeinflussen gerade auch über
die weihnachtstage
für alle möchten wir die feiertage mit
familie und freunden verbringen aber wir
alle müssen auch gemeinsam dafür sorgen
dass weihnachten nicht zu einem kick
start für omicron wird sondern im
gegenteil dass wir diese zeit zwischen
den jahren wirklich nutzen um die
dynamik aus dem infektionsgeschehen
rauszunehmen daher meine eindringliche
bitte lassen sie uns die feiertage so
verbringen dass sie nicht für das virus
ein festwirt verbringen sie diese zeit
wirklich nur im kleinsten engsten
freundes und familienkreis
bitte schenken sie ihre kontakte auf das
nötigste eintreffen die möglichst wenig
und wenn dann immer dieselben menschen
in einem festen sozialen kreis und am
besten etablieren sie diesen kreis schon
vorher jetzt schon in der
vorweihnachtszeit
und klar ist dass es am sichersten ist
wenn alle vollständig geimpft und eine
dritte impfung erhalten haben wenn sie
sich mit menschen aus risikogruppen
treffen zb mithalten oder chronisch
kranke sollten sie auf jeden fall auch
vorher testen auch wenn sie geimpft sind
also mit micon geraten wir erneut in
eine schwierige lage es herrscht eine
gewisse unsicherheit weil diese variante
neu ist und die datenlage noch sehr
dynamisch noch können wir aber einige
fragen nicht beantworten aber was auf
jeden fall wissen ist dass alle
präventionsmaßnahmen helfen die wir
schon kennen je stärker sie umgesetzt
werden desto besser und je mehr menschen
zusammenkommen desto größer ist das
kontaktnetzwerk desto leichter und
schneller verbreitet sich das virus
darum bitten dieses netzwerk kleiner wir
können das nämlich wirklich vermeiden
durch unsere eigenes verhalten das
spielt eine entscheidende rolle unser
eigenes verhalten und wir müssen schnell
impfen aber nochmal impfstoffe sind noch
keine wunderwaffe wir müssen aus dieser
achterbahn aussteigen in der weser zwei
jahren fahren und wir können das nur
erreichen wenn wir zusammen daran
arbeiten und alle werkzeuge nutzen zum
infektionsschutz dann können wir
gemeinsam dafür sorgen dass sich die
bevorstehende bekommt würde gar nicht
erst so hoch aufbauen kann
vielen dank meine sehr verehrten damen
und herren ich darf ihnen zunächst von
der aktuellen situation und der
gefährlichkeit der kogit 19 infektionen
für kinder und jugendliche berichten
hier haben wir an den kinderkliniken in
deutschland jetzt eine stabile situation
wir haben relativ wenige stationäre
patienten mit einer akuten cupid 19
infektion so dass im moment keine
überlastung der kinder und jugendklinik
droht ihm endlich auf die zweite
erkrankungswelle station das sogenannte
pimps syndrom erleben wird derzeit unter
der delta variante eher milde verlauf
bzw ein abflauen der verläufe so dass
auch hier eine gewisse entspannung
eingetreten ist zum dritten die
long beach situation bei kindern und
jugendlichen ist nach wie vor nicht ganz
geklärt es gibt auf jeden fall
altersabhängig bei älteren jugendlichen
kurvenverläufe als bei jungen kindern
insgesamt ist aber die datenlage dazu
noch relativ unklar
was müssen wir erwarten im hinblick auf
omikron hier sind natürlich die daten
noch sehr vage aus der auswertung der
südafrikanischen daten wissen wir dass
die initiale annahme dass omikron
deutlich schwerer verläuft bei den
kindern und jugendlichen als die anderen
varianten sich nicht zu bestätigen
scheint vor dem hintergrund natürlich
der südafrikanischen situation es ist so
dass in etwa die infektionen
beziehungsweise die hospitalisationen
unter delta in südafrika um 50 prozent
zurückgehen unter den ursprünglichen
variante gegenüber den ursprünglichen
varianten und jetzt mutter omikron bei
sehr niedrigen fallzahlen insgesamt
deswegen immer auch dieses von
sicherheits moment um circa 20 prozent
wieder ansteigen dh gegenüber den
ursprünglichen varianten haben wir in
südafrika zumindest unter omikron nach
wie vor keine scherer verläufe gegenüber
der ausgangssituation
zum dritten und das ist ein ganz
wichtiger punkt die situation der
schulen sind die schulen sicher ist es
sinnvoll die schulen offen zu halten er
zeigt sich natürlich dass sich kinder
sowohl in schulen wie im haushalt
anstecken können es ist auf der anderen
seite so dass die daten über das gesamte
jahr zeigen dass die ansteckungsraten in
den schulen trotz
ansteckender varianten gleich blieben
während die ansteckungsraten in den
familien und haushalten gleichzeitig
entsprechend der höheren
ansteckungsfähigkeit des virus gestiegen
sind dies ist zu verdanken und
insbesondere zu sehen wenn die schulen
besonders
konkret und akkurat die schutzmaßnahmen
einhalten die profile auch gerade
angesprochen hat und dazu zählen wir
ausdrücklich auch das masken tragen das
ja mittlerweile wieder verbindlich an
allen schulen ist es ist weiterhin
festzustellen und das sind daten auf
basis von über 13 millionen testung den
nordrhein westfalen durchgeführt wurden
mit der sogenannten lolli testmethode
die sie alle kennen das insbesondere in
den ferien besonders viele infektionen
stattgefunden haben und die kinder aus
den ferien in die schulen mit hohen
infektionsraten zurückkehrten es ist
nach den sommerferien dann gelungen die
hohen infektionsraten in
nordrhein-westfalen durch das sehr gut
ausgeklügelte testsystem schnell wieder
zu senken nach den herbstferien ist eine
stabilisierung möglich gewesen die wie
gesagt den herbstferien selbst nicht
möglich war insofern tragen schulen ganz
klar auch zur regulation und zur
kontrolle desinfektions geschehens bei
sofern und das betone ich hier noch
einmal die hygienemaßnahmen inklusive
das masken tragen konsequent eingehalten
werden
der vierte punkt der mir auch sehr
wichtig ist wir empfehlen
uneingeschränkt die impfungen der 12 bis
17 jährigen das
nutzen-risiko-verhältnis ist eindeutig
zugunsten der impfung zu sehen 12 bis 17
jährige haben ein minimal gesteigertes
risiko eine
herzmuskelentzündung zu bekommen selbst
nach pessimistischen schätzungen sind
das etwa jedes zehntausendste kind oder
jeder jugendliche der betroffenen ist in
dieser altersgruppe und wir wissen von
allen bisher statt gehabten
herzmuskelentzündungen dass diese
reversibel das heißt wieder zur
gesundung geführt haben
was geht was wie ist die situation bei
den fünf- bis elfjährigen hier sind vier
verschiedene szenarien zu unterscheiden
die kinder die eine chronische
erkrankung haben zu diesem gehört im
übrigen jetzt auch das asthma bronchiale
das schwerer asthma bronchiale hinzu
sollten unbedingt geimpft werden ebenso
sollten unbedingt die kinder geimpft
werden die mit familienangehörigen in
einem haushalt leben die selbst nicht
geimpft werden können aber zur risiko
bevölkerung zählen die dritte
konstellation ist die erste die
scheinbar schwierig ist wie sollte man
verfahren wenn die eltern überzeugt sind
dass die impfung die richtige maßnahme
ist und wenn sie die bisher viel
versprechenden geringen meldungen von
nebenwirkungen aus den usa kennen und
sagen wir möchten unser kind gerne
kämpfen hier empfiehlt die ständige
impfkommission und das gehen wir ganz
klar mit dann auch wirklich zu impfen
denn es handelt sich um einen
zugelassenen impfstoff
er ist europäisch und national
zugelassen und wie schon gesagt die
ersten daten sprechen für eine geringe
nebenwirkungsfreie
es stellt sich jetzt natürlich ferner
die frage wie eltern vorgehen sollen
wenn sie sich noch unsicher fühlen wenn
sie abwarten möchten dass die
wissenschaftliche evaluation durch die
stiko die im übrigen erst erfolgen kann
wenn die da wirklich aufbereitet sind
und wenn sie wirklich wissenschaftlich
valide sind wie soll man vorgehen in der
situation wenn man sich unsicher fühlt
dann ist es sinnvoll zu warten bis die
stiko dieser empfehlung ausspricht man
ist in jedem fall als eltern wie auch
immer sich man sich entscheidet man ist
dann in einer verantwortungsvollen
situation sowohl wenn man seine kinder
jetzt impfen lässt als auch wenn man
wartet und das ist mir ganz wichtig an
dieser stelle dass eltern nicht das
gefühl bekommen durch irgendjemanden
stigmatisiert zu sein oder
irgendjemanden kritisiert zu sein wenn
sie eher zu der einen oder zu der
anderen haltung tendieren aber ich
möchte es auch nochmal ausdrücklich
sagen wer jetzt überzeugt ist sein kind
zwischen fünf und elf impfen zu lassen
den würden wir sehr gerne zu raten dies
auch zu tun vielen dank für die
aufmerksamkeit wir danken ihnen wir
haben jetzt eine gute halbe stunde zeit
für fragen wir sind schon zahlreich
eingetroffen beziehungsweise die
wortmeldungen dazu die dringende bitte
bitte stellen sie eine frage der
ebenfalls eine nachfrage adressieren sie
die frage und lassen sie uns so schauen
dass wir gut durch diese halbe stunde
kommt da fangen an frau kollegin und
stellen sie sich bitte an und lassen sie
die maske bitte auf dieser braun
presseagentur gesundheit ich habe eine
frage an den minister und zwar hat er
bei seiner oder herr minister haben sie
bei ihrer inventur auch nur die
impfstoffe angeguckt aber auch spritzen
und kanülen brot und es da eine
knappheit
wir haben uns ausschließlich zunächst
einmal mit den eben stoffen beschäftigt
aber eben aus wird auch die
verfügbarkeit von spritzen und kanülen
regelhaft monitor irrt und so kann ihnen
dazu auf anfrage auskunft erteilen über
das haus selbst aber die knappheit
betrifft zum jetzigen zeitpunkt die
neben stoff und nicht die utensilien
zusatzfrage stichwort inventur damit
krieg ich auch meine zusage gut und wir
wissen jetzt genau wieviel
intensivbetten wir in deutschland haben
was wissen wir darüber wie viel welche
operationen verschoben wurden auch schon
aus den ersten wellen und wie wollen wir
die bei vollen krankenhäusern jemals
wieder nachholen
also eine schwierige frage wir haben
hinweise darauf dass die also dass das
verschieben von allen dürfen
zu also auch einer möglicherweise
erhöhung der sterblichkeit führt weil
wir in den regionen wo derzeit die
inzidenz besonders hoch ist wie eine
stärke über sterblichkeit messen als in
anderen regionen und das gibt grund zum
anlass zu glauben dass es also
möglicherweise nicht nur die sterbefälle
durch profis sind sondern dass durch die
also nicht durchführung von bestimmt
durch das verschieben von bestimmten
angriffen zu einer über sterblichkeit
kommen könnte die frage lässt sich
allerdings nur beantworten auf der
grundlage einer wirklich soliden
wissenschaftlichen
untersuchungen und die liegt zum
jetzigen zeitpunkt nicht vor
markus 11 im rundfunk
herr minister vor zwei tagen hat ihr
haus eine zahlen veröffentlicht wie
viele impfstoffe an die ärzte und
impfzentren ausgeliefert werden es ist
in dieser woche 18,7 millionen dosen
nächste woche 11 millionen durch
übernächste woche auch 11 millionen das
heißt bis jahresende
40,7 millionen dosen stimmen diese
zahlen oder stehe man diese zahlen nicht
zu
langsamer wie viel also ausgeliefert
werden hängt davon ab was bestellt wird
und ich kann ihnen zum beispiel also nur
vortragen was jetzt beispielsweise für
die nächste woche gilt weil die
bestellungen für die nächste woche sind
schon eingegangen und werden und von uns
am anfang der nächsten woche bedient uns
für die nächste woche gilt dass es also
acht millionen bestellungen gab und es
werden ausgeliefert 4,6 millionen das
sind die zahlen
für die nächste woche das haus kann ja
auch nicht vorab zu sagen wieviel
ausgeliefert wird wenn die bestellungen
noch nicht vorliegen wir haben jedes mal
also funktioniert so dass ihr mittwochs
die bestellungen bekommen dann prüfen
wir also welche bestellungen wir
bedienen können und
bedienen diese montags und die woche die
jetzt also auswertbar ist für mich wo
ich jungen im amt bin ist also die jetzt
laufende woche weil für diese woche die
bestellungen habe und auch war es was
wir davon also ausliefern können 8
millionen bestellungen und 4,6 millionen
werden wir ausliefern
die
situation ist auch wie folgt ich habe
ich lese und eine menge also was sagen
kolportiert wird aus dem haus games
wartungs wort habe ich zum beispiel auch
gelesen dass also noch bei montech
impfstoff da wäre für die für die
letzten wochen das stimmt aber wir
hatten noch eine reserve von insgesamt
drei millionen dosen biotec und dann
habe ich entschieden im einvernehmen mit
der fachabteilung dass wir davon also
1,2 millionen für die nächste woche also
zur verfügung stellen
0,8 die woche darauf und noch einmal 1,2
millionen in der ersten januarwoche mit
in der annahme dass die woche zwar quasi
zwischen
weihnachten und neujahr die woche ist wo
am wenigsten verändern aber wir sind
derzeit in einer knappheit und ich
arbeite fieberhaft daran selbige zu
beseitigen und ich muss hier
ausdrücklich darauf hinweisen dass
tatsächlich das unternehmen moderner
zusammen mit der europäischen kommission
frau von der leyen selbst
sehr hilfreich gewesen ist um also
kurzfristig impfstoff zu beschaffen
das heißt also diese 40 millionen dosen
geliefert werden an die wachsende in die
sie vor zwei tagen veröffentlicht haben
die sind irgendwie fiktiv wenn ich das
richtig verstehe dann die nachfrage sie
haben vorher gesagt sie brauchen für die
booster impfungen
im ersten quartal 50 millionen dosen
jetzt sind ja bereits 23 millionen us
dollar verabreicht und deutschland hat
ja nur 83 millionen einwohner das heißt
wenn sie 50 millionen booster dosen
brauchen dann rechnen sie dass jeder
erwachsene 100 prozent in deutschland
eine große dosis braucht plus auch
kinder und jugendliche eine booster
dosis brauchen nein die also 23 also
millionen sind berücksichtigt und also
wir gehen davon aus dass wir insgesamt
73 millionen
booster impfungen unter optimalen
bedingungen durchführen können und für
diese 73 millionen oster impfungen die
wir insgesamt durchführen können
brauchen wir 50 millionen dosen die wir
noch nicht gesetzt haben und dann
brauchen wir darüber hinaus noch also 20
millionen erste und zweite impfung somit
sehr stark also verkürzt gesagt 50
millionen booster dosen
zusätzlich zu den 23 millionen booster
dosen die wir bereits verabreicht haben
und also 20 millionen erst zwei dosen
und da somit kommt man auf einen
gesamtbedarf von 70 millionen dosen und
die könnten wir bis ende märz nicht
abdecken weil wir haben 50 millionen
dosen anlieferung bisher zu erwarten
gehabt und darüber hinaus ist es auch
viel zu langsam selbiges bis also märz
zu applizieren das hat so an das tempo
enorm beschleunigen wir wollen auch
vorbereitet zahlen darauf dass zb erster
bestimmte impfungen bevorzugen dem
stoffe bevorzugen und wir müssen auch
mit schwund rechnen mit vorwurf rechnen
wir müssen damit rechnen dass impfstoff
also besteht wird aber nicht genutzt
wird für mich ist wirklich relevant dass
wir dieses enorme tempo dieses
großartige tempo jetzt aufgenommen haben
anstatt ein höheres tempo als jedes
andere europäische land und ich möchte
nicht dass dieses tempo aus der bams in
dem ich hier also den impfstoff
aktionäre über die nächsten drei monaten
ich möchte einfach dass mehr impfstoff
da ist das muss anders ausgedrückt
werden ich möchte einfach dass deutlich
mehr impfstoff da ist aus abgerufen wird
um zu jedem zeitpunkt die impfstoff
bedarfe ohne verzug decken zu können ich
möchte eine online frage einschieben von
frank buchholz vom zdf die geht an
professor sie gehören dem experten
gremium der bundesregierung an sind sie
optimistisch dass wissenschaft und
politik beim thema kinderimpfungen zu
einer gemeinsamen empfehlung kommen
wir
möchten im expertengremium
beraten können und dann gemeinsam auch
nach außen kommunizieren deswegen würde
ich jetzt um verständnis bitten an
dieser stelle wenn ich jetzt zum
jetzigen zeitpunkt nichts direkt aus der
arbeit des expertengremiums sagen kann
ich möchte aber dann gleichzeitig meinem
einem festen einer festen überzeugung
ausdruck verleihen dass all diejenigen
die in dem expertengremium das die
bundesregierung berät sind sehr sehr
stark daran interessiert sind gemeinsam
für unser land für unsere bevölkerung
und auch für die verschiedenen
besonders zu berücksichtigen dann
gruppen wie die kinder und jugendliche
die so stark gelitten haben durch die
schulschließung die so viele psychische
und körperliche erkrankungen erlebt
haben durch die einschränkungen die sie
hatten dass dieses expertengremium auch
für diese gruppen insbesondere
denken wird und eine gute lösung eine
gute beratung für unsere politischen
entscheidungsträger versuchen wird
vorzubereiten
hallo ich bin von der bild zeitung die
hier minister lauterbach
sie haben berichtet von 35 millionen
moderner die jetzt im ersten hinzu
kommen das sind dann quasi 70 millionen
mögliche booster impfungen
gibt welches problem stellt da das mit
der nikon variante möglicherweise doch
eine ganze dose moderner möglich oder
nicht notwendig sein könnte und eine
zweite frage
also sehr gut also sehr wichtige frage
in der tat also
wer derzeit bei moderner erwogen die
booster dosis also als doppel also als
voll großes zu applizieren und dann
schrumpft natürlich das was wir also
hier erreichen konnten auf 17 einhalb
millionen dosen das ist klar und ich
hatte ja schon darauf hingewiesen dass
wir über das was ich gerade vorgetragen
habe hinaus versuchen impfstoff zu
beschaffen in mehreren ländern mit den
bilateralen gesprächen sind rumänien
bulgarien portugal aber holen sodass wir
also tatsächlich mehr impfstoff noch
beschaffen wollen über das also
kontingent was wir jetzt haben zum
jetzigen zeitpunkt ist diese empfehlung
noch nicht ausgesprochen dass es somit
auch unter ob sie kommen es gibt auch
daten beispielsweise bei biotech dass
also die halbe dosis von bayer als
booster dosis möglicherweise auch gut
werden somit also ist das auch sehr viel
wissenschaftlich zu klären
nichtsdestotrotz ist das was sie
vorgetragen haben etwas was derzeit
erwogen wird
und es gibt aber keine braucht es gibt
keine belastbaren daten dazu
oder nachfrage
die dosen moderner resultierende jetzt
auch aus einer vorgezogenen lieferungen
ebenso wie diese große bayern texte die
über die eu kommission kommt ist es so
dass solche chancen lieferung
vorzuziehen vergangenheit ausgelassen
wurden
ich hatte ja schon also gesagt dass das
was ich hier mache immer was wir machen
was das haus macht uns einfach neben
olaf scholz machen muss ganz so schwarz
dass das nicht in irgendeiner weise zu
sehen ist als eine kritik an der
vorgehensweise des vorvorgängers das ist
einfach nicht ich gehe transparent damit
um euch von anfang an gemacht war mal in
meiner antrittsrede als minister im
bundestag habe ich erklärt dass also für
mich selbst die also österreich
strategie die extrem forcierte booster
impfung strategie ein zentraler baustein
sein wird um die data variante
zurückzubringen und die omikron variante
also
zurückzudrängen dahingehend dass sie gar
nicht diese größe
wir müssen dass es sehr schnell sein und
daher ist das eine neue strategie und
für diese neue strategie braucht man
sehr viel impfstoff und den beschaffen
wir gerade weil es einfach sonst nicht
funktioniert wir haben in deutschland
derzeit also eine große bereitschaft
wo ist der impfungen zu nehmen und wir
haben eine sehr große bereitschaft in
der erste schafft bussler impfungen zu
organisieren und auf die eben zentren
arbeiten mit einer enormen
geschwindigkeit das ist beeindruckend
ich möchte mich bei dieser gelegenheit
bevor ich da überhaupt warte aus für
möchte ich mich ausdrücklich bedanken
bei den vielen kolleginnen und kollegen
die das machen ich möchte mich
ausdrücklich bedanken bei den ersten und
ersten diese impfungen die diese
impfzentren aufbauen die das
dokumentieren das ist eine wichtige
arbeit ich bin ja bis vor kurzem kann
ich jetzt nicht mehr machen
verständlicherweise auch selbst
ebenfalls gewesen und ich weiß wie viel
zeit dort auch wie viel freizeit
geopfert werden da möchte ich mich
ganzen bedanken und was wir aus
gesundheitsministerium hierzu liefern
haben ist dass der impfstoff wirklich
dann auch da ist denn das ist ein
ärgernis was wir in der nächsten woche
erleben werden das auch so viel bestellt
wird und es kann da nicht geliefert
werden
dann sind wir behandeln wenn auch sie
sich kurz vorstellen ja herr lauterbach
esther grimm von der augsburger
allgemeinen lauterbach mich hat heute
eine leserin angerufen ludwig 80 jahre
und die hat mir einen fall geschildert
dem soll ich ihn unbedingt vorbringen
und das will ich auch tun sie sorgt sich
darum dass die booster impfung zu spät
kommen könnte bei ihr weil es länger her
ist als sechs monate und sie fragt sich
dann ob der impfschutz nach der booster
impfung
quasi nur so gut ist wie als würde sie
ihre erste impfung erhalten weil eben
die ersten beiden immunisierung schon
länger als sechs monate her sind und der
antikörper spiegel gefallen ist oder
bringt die dritte impfung an einen
deutlich verbesserten schutz
vielen dank sie können der damen
mitteilen dass die booster impfung nie
zu spät ist das also ist immer eine sehr
gute
impfung
frühestens medizin nicht gesprochen also
na ja das lassen wir das einmal lag aber
auf jeden fall also die die impfung nach
sechs monaten auf jeden fall sehr
wirksam und bei der delta war ja steigt
der schutz wirklich sehr stark an die
bei der omicron variante mit der wir
rechnen müssen stark der schutz wie eben
ausgeführt auf der grundlage der ersten
also
feldstudien in england
niveau von ungefähr 70 bis 80 prozent
die schutzwirkung vor schweren verläufen
ist zum jetzigen zeitpunkt noch unklar
aber die brust 1 punkt auf jeden fall
für jemand 80 jahre altes nicht nur da
sondern es dringend zu empfehlen
und sie wäre daher definitiv gut beraten
die booster impfung vornehmen zu lassen
dann
ja auch eine frage der minister markus
pohl von er die kontraste herr
lauterbach die ampel hatte ein aussicht
gestellt dass im februar spätestens märz
die allgemeine impfpflicht kommt jetzt
stellt sich natürlich die frage was
bedeutet denn der jetzt festgestellte
mangel an impfstoff für diese pläne
schnell eine allgemeine dienstpflicht
einzuführen
vielen dank
wer die impfpflicht wird ja debattiert
im deutschen bundestag als eine
entscheidung des parlaments eine
gewissensfrage und somit ist das also
nichts was beispielsweise das
ministerium einen für das gehirn das
museum oder die regierung sondern dass
es an der parlamentsentscheidung ich bin
persönlich das sage ich bei dieser
gelegenheit und da spreche ich wirklich
immer funktion als
bundestagsabgeordneter und nicht als
minister aber ich bin als
bundestagsabgeordneter von der
einführung einer allgemeinen impfpflicht
überzeugt ich bin der meinung dass wir
also die so varianten die wir also zu
befürchten haben die wir jetzt haben mit
also werten von 3 bis 5 dass dies also
sehr schwer zu beherrschen sein wird
ohne eine allgemeine pflicht jetzt habe
ich aber als abgeordneter ich brauche
ich komme jetzt wieder zurück zu meiner
rolle als minister nämlich werden es
eine solche gibt dann muss natürlich der
impfstoff da sein und da kann ich ihnen
versichern daran arbeiten wir es wurde
ja eben schon angesprochen also das was
wir jetzt moderner zu erwarten haben 35
millionen dosen die impfstoffe die ich
versuche zu beschaffen über die bieler
in die bilateralen gespräche geführt
werden und darüber hinaus natürlich also
diese 80 millionen dosen impfstoff die
wir versuchen zu beschaffen über die
europäische kommission von biotech
selbst somit also glaube ich dass wir
zum schluss also sollte es zu einer
impfpflicht kommen
das wäre genug impfstoff hatten
noch ein kurzer zusatz nochmal zu den 23
sie schlagen ist die entscheidung des
parlaments aber auch der bundeskanzler
selbst hat ja hat er sozusagen diese
zeithorizont vorgegeben februar anfang
märz angesichts dessen was sie
vorgetragen haben muss man doch
eigentlich klar sagen ist in dieser
kürze zu schaffen ist doch im grunde
genommen illusorisch weil man kann ja
schlecht die leute verpflichten sich
impfen zu lassen wenn noch nicht mal für
diejenigen die jetzt schon billig sind
genug impfstoff da ist ich glaube dass
wir bis dahin deutlich mehr impfstoff
haben ich hatte ja schon darauf
hingewiesen dass wir seit letztem
wochenende sehr intensiv also an dem
problem arbeiten und ich glaube dass wir
es wissen können
dann herr kollege bitte bitte stellt
überhaupt andre dos santos ich habe sie
nicht verstanden jan drebes eine show
post ich hätte eine frage bei ihm
vorgeworfen wird sie hätten jetzt für
ihre rechnungen auch bezahlen
verwechselt und
hätten sozusagen alarm geschlagen ohne
zahlen vorzulegen können sie noch mal
ganz genau erklären wie sie jetzt auf
diese lücke von 70 bis 80 millionen
kommen die fehlen und inwiefern
sozusagen der bestand überhaupt noch da
ist also wie viel liegt noch in den
lagern beziehungsweise bei den
arztpraxen findet ist
ja vielen dank also zunächst mal also
ich weiß nicht worauf sie hier bezug
nehmen wenn sie von einer lücke von 70
bis 80 millionen
sie sparen hier gerade davon dass es
eine sozusagen jetzt für das nächste
jahr 17 millionen extra dosen brauche
ich ja ich habe also vorgetragen wie
viel also wir hier haben das ist ja auch
so transparent kommuniziert und
die also
mengen die wir bisher also erwarten
können die gesichert sind die
liefermengen die an die quasi an uns
geliefert werden das sind eben die und
50 millionen bis ende märz
und also dann habe ich dargestellt wie
der bedarf ist ein booster impfungen 23
millionen sind gewusst hat 50 millionen
müssen zusätzlich bewässert werden also
50 millionen bedarf und zusätzliche 20
millionen erster und zweiter das war so
nicht die lücke in dem sinne ich
beschreibe was die was der bestand ist
und selbstverständlich ist es so wenn
man jetzt mal mit wegen nicht alle brust
sondern weniger und bewusster langsam
meinetwegen bis ende märz und hat auch
eine situation dass überhaupt kein
einziges böses verlobter also verloren
so kann man ganz ordentlich zurecht aber
das ist ja nicht das wovon ich ausgehe
sondern ich gehe von dem aus was ich
bisher beobachtet ich betrachte das
ehrlich gesagt von praktischen länder
auch aus meiner erfahrung als ebenfalls
ich kann nicht wirklich vortrag und wir
haben genug impfstoff wenn nächste woche
die ihm die ärzte sagen aber wir haben
nur die hälfte des bestellten bekommen
dann hilft es mir nicht dass ich darauf
hinweise aber ja doch in der
vergangenheit schon uns erwartungsvoll
sondern ich muss mit ich muss mit dem
arbeiten was praktisch notwendig ist und
schnell fertig zu werden ich kann dann
nicht mit einer excel-tabelle die erste
also überzeugen dass sie genug impfstoff
hätten der war sie mich stellen und
bekommen ich will das einfach bedienen
können damit wir dieses tempo halten
dieses aus meiner sicht olle tempo das
schnellste booster tempo derzeit in
europa was über es war vorgänger mit
angestoßen hat damit wir uns nicht
falsch verstehen also keine kritik da
hingeht und ja das ist ja so dass
die also ich meine
das problem liegt ja auf der hand in dem
sinne und ich werde es auch lösen wie
beschrieben wir brauchen den impfstoff
denen wir benötigen um dieses besonders
hohe tempo bei der booster impfung zu
schaffen
frage ist weil sie gesagt hatten dass
merz ist zu langsam deadline setzen sie
denn dann für das ostern ist das was
muss man sozusagen für umgekommen also
ideal wäre tatsächlich wenn es uns
gelingt genug impfstoff zu besorgen dass
man die kinder derzeit also eine
endgeschwindigkeit von 1 bis 1 5
millionen impfungen pro tag die höchsten
geschwindigkeit die wir bisher gehabt
haben das heißt wenn das hat sich
fortgesetzt werden könnte dann wären
dann könnten wir im januar schon einen
großen teil dieser booster impflücken
schließen das wäre optimal dafür muss
der impfstoff aber da sein und wie
gesagt ich verhandle derzeit mit der
kommission und mit moderner möglichst
viel impfstoff nach vorne zu ziehen eine
erste lieferung von also voraussichtlich
zehn millionen werden wir noch im
dezember bekommen das ist der derzeitige
verhandlungsstand und dann versuche ich
den rest auch so weit nach vorne zu
ziehen wie es irgend geht war die
schnelle kommunikation schnell kommen
dass wir uns an diese also sagen wir
bemühungen noch erinnern werden wir
müssen wirklich wie also die die
impfungen im märz sind für eine also für
eine rasend schnell verbreitete omikron
variante nicht mehr wirklich relevant
sondern wir sprechen wirklich über die
frühen wochen im nächsten jahr
omikron andreas uber zdf
hauptstadtstudio mit einer frage an
professor wieder wie wichtig ist das
sequenzieren um einschätzen zu können
wie weit sich bereits ausgebreitet hat
bzw wird bereits genug sequenziert
verlässliche daten zu bekommen
also es gibt ja zwei methoden wie das
nachgewiesen wird das eine ist die
sequenz analyse wo man das ganze erbgut
entschlüsseln und das andere sind
natürlich auch pcr tests die ja
schneller gehen auch direkt ergebnis
haben beides wird in ausreichendem maße
durchgeführt wir haben hier etwa dadurch
dass wir diese gesetzliche regel haben
dass die finanzielle entschädigung dafür
hoch ist werden sehr viele sequenzen
eingereicht ich habe dir im weltweit
inzwischen und 6 millionen sequenzen und
in deutschland habe ich die zahl
tatsächlich nicht im kopf die waren am
nikon haben sind mehrere hundert die wir
bereits in deutschland auch schon haben
ja das ist ausreichend und wir sehen
aber auch dass jetzt die labore auch
noch vermehrt wieder sequenzieren also
wir haben eine stichproben wir auch drei
verschiedenen stichproben das hatte ich
mal erläutert die wir die sequenzen
erhalten wir haben genügend ergebnis um
zu wissen was in deutschland unterwegs
ist ja
mehr impfdosen vorhalten will näher als
jede woche abgerufen werden das haben
sie ja gerade erläutert als die was
bedeutet das für impfdosen die
bereitschaft deutschlands inzwischen zu
spenden ob jetzt im rahmen von kovacs
oder anderen kontext und bedient sich
deutschland schon aus diesen
kontingenten
ja vielen dank also der impfstoff den
wir jetzt also kaufen beispielsweise von
beim weg über die europäische kommission
der wird produziert in einer branche von
etwa oder nicht von etwa von so bisher
geplant 160 millionen dosen und davon
nehmen wir die hälfte wenn dieses wenn
diese also starke nachfrage von uns
nicht also
dokumentiert worden wäre wäre diese
branche möglicherweise gar nicht
zustande gekommen und dann wäre im stoff
nicht da in dem es produziert damit er
also verkauft werden kann und ich glaube
dass wir sehr darauf achten müssen dass
die art und weise wie wir unseren dem
stoff ansätzen nicht zu lasten von
anderen ländern wird daher sind mir auch
so beispielsweise solche kombinationen
wie wir es gerade gemacht haben die sind
mir im prinzip also
wichtig wir nehmen hier impfstoff den
wir ohnedies bekommen hätte nach vorne
oder wir verursachen das neue branchen
verkauft und somit jetzt produziert
werden er war das geht nicht zulasten
ärmerer länder was ich problematisch
finde ist der rückkauf von dosen von
kovacs das hat auch stattgefunden und
findet immer wieder statt und
das empfinde ich persönlich als also
also eine eher problematische lösung
schließen sich also aus dass deutschland
solche rückkäufe macht
zum jetzigen zeitpunkt haben wir es auf
jeden fall obwohl wir aus meiner sicht
das ja eine subjektive einschätzung
so sehr viel impfstoff jetzt brauchen
haben wir das nicht verfolgt dann
vergessen bitte mit der nächsten frage
johansson freier journalist ich hätte
eine frage zur kinder irgendwo erhöht
sie sagten vorhin wenn ich es recht
verstanden habe alle fünf bis
elfjährigen seien willkommen die
ständige impfkommission stiko hat
allerdings wenn ich das richtig sehe
keine allgemeine impfempfehlung für
diese altersgruppe ausgesprochen weil
nicht genügend daten vorliegen sondern
die empfehlungen für risikokinder und
angehörige von risikopatienten haben sie
andere datenlage oder worauf basiert
ihre dann doch sehr allgemeiner
einladung das völlig richtig was sie
sagen die stiko empfiehlt die impfung
letztlich nicht für alle kinder in
dieser altersgruppe sie bringt aber auch
ganz klar zum ausdruck dass dies auf
basis noch nicht vollständiger
wissenschaftlicher daten zu den
nebenwirkungen ist und sie bringt auch
sehr deutlich zum ausdruck dass es jedem
kind jeder familie geht impfenden
kinderarzt möglich ist bei überzeugung
der entsprechenden partner die impfung
durchzuführen da es sich um einen
zugelassenen impfstoff handelt insofern
sind wir mit unseren empfehlungen von
seiten auch der fachgesellschaften ganz
eindeutig auf der linie der ständigen
impfkommission
so seien zu essen zusatz da sie auch
ausgeführt haben dass die verläufe bei
kindern wenn überhaupt dann doch sehr
milde ausfallen wenn impfstoff knapp
bleibt wäre es dann nicht eine plausible
überlegung zu sagen dann nehmen wir den
lieber für erwachsene die höher und
stärker gefährdet sind
ich stimme ihnen insofern zu als es ein
ganz besonders wichtiges moment ist
jetzt die booster impfung bei den
erwachsenen durchzuführen dass es
überhaupt gar keine frage und das wird
sehr viel schneller zu einem schutz in
den familien führen als die impfung der
kinder dass es alleine aus den
vorlaufzeiten einer vollständigen
impfung bei kindern zu errechnen
gleichzeitig muss man auch sagen dass
die derzeit zur verfügung gestellten
darreichungsformen letztlich nur für
diese altersgruppe bestimmt sind das
heißt sie können nicht einfach in einer
anderen altersgruppe verwendet werden
insofern ist hier alleine aufgrund der
impfstoff logistik die zuteilung
bestimmter rationen zu den kindern
erfolgt
lauterbach ich hätte ganz gerne nein
auch sie sich kurz vorstellen andreas
rinke von reuters ich hätte ganz gerne
nach der vierten impfung gefragt die sie
erwähnt haben können sie das zeitliche
eingrenzen wann die kommen muss also das
wird ja dann die sein die vor allem
gegen um die krone auch schon den
angepassten impfstoff haben wird wann
kommt die und wie viele impfdosen haben
wir eigentlich im gesamten nächsten jahr
zur verfügung oder müssen wir zur
verfügung haben
ob und wann die fährte impfung notwendig
ist dass stets zum jetzigen zeitpunkt
nicht fest und dazu gibt es auch keine
wissenschaftlichen studien es ist
allerdings
in fachkreisen
[Musik]
durch ist das durchaus eine diskussion
weil wir sehen dass mit der booster
impfung bei omikron eine neben schutz
nur von 70 bis 80 prozent erreicht
werden kann und das ist der eben schutz
unmittelbar nach der booster impfung
somit typischerweise der impfschutz so
nach einiger zeit nachlässt könnte sehr
gut sein dass eine oregon spezifische
impfung später notwendig wird
feiertag und also moderne arbeiten an
solchen impfstoffen soll es mit sehr
unterschiedlichen strategien und
technologien
und man kann zum jetzigen zeitpunkt aber
nicht sagen ob und wann fast notwendig
ist ich habe es auf jeden fall also wie
folgt gehandhabt
wir haben das wie folgt gehandhabt als
haus wir haben uns überlegt wie er dann
erfährt dem stoff eine info werte eben
notwendig wäre wie können wir
sicherstellen dass wir also frühzeitig
einen angepassten impfstoff also der
deutschen bevölkerung auch anbieten
können und das ist der grund weshalb ich
diese 80 millionen
impfstoff
nicht nur optiert habe sondern quasi gar
die haben viel platz bundesregierung um
diese möglichkeit einer vierten impfung
städte auch vollziehen zu können
die frage nach der gesamtmenge die
nächstes jahr nötig ist
hänge also ich steht noch nicht fest
weil wir derzeit umfänglicher also
beschaffungsmaßnahmen
machen und dazu könnte ich vielleicht
also bei der nächsten gelegenheit ihnen
etwas mittag habe mich jetzt erst mal
auf die nächsten drei monate
konzentriert was die dort nächsten drei
monate angeht das ist das was sie also
hier ausgedruckt vorgefunden haben
lustig 35 millionen moderner die wir
jetzt also im ersten quartal erwarten
und dann möglicherweise zusätzlichen
stoff den ich in den ländern versuche zu
beschaffen den wir in den ländern
versuchen zu beschaffen die ich eben
aufgezählt habe wir bleiben in der reihe
wechseln das mikrofon die nächste frage
bitte
minister lauterbach geograf ein paar
gespiegelt also sie müssten ein bisschen
näher ans mikro er tut mir leid ich habe
hier eine frage jetzt nochmal zum januar
seien im prinzip den januar wenn ich
richtig verstehe zum entscheidenden
monat aufgerufen wenn man dort jetzt die
neue auflistung sieht ist dass der monat
wo es die größten engpässe gibt wo wir
wirklich nur etwa
3,6 millionen booster dosen bis 3,5
millionen booster dosen zur verfügung
haben beim jetzigen tempo von etwa einer
million das 1 5 millionen am tag
bedeutet dass das ist schrecklich
erheblichen mangel gibt
können sie garantieren dass das jetzt
auch mit den neuen zusagen von moderner
kurzfristig ja im prinzip so geregelt
werden kann dass genug impfstoff auch in
den ersten januarwochen
ja das
hoffe ich garantieren zu können aber sie
beschreiben das problem er ist mal nehme
schaden das problem wir haben in der
letzten dezemberwoche und in den vier
januar wochen haben wir voraussetzung
sehr viel mehr impfstoff bedarf im sinne
von anmeldungen für impfstoffe in den
impfzentren und bei den niedergelassenen
kollegen als wir derzeit also gesichert
im stoff haben das heißt ich habe dafür
gekämpft dass wir den moderner hemmstoff
so früh wie möglich bekommen und wir
sind uns sind zehn millionen zugesagt
für also dezember und ich hoffe einen so
großen anteil wie möglich in den januar
zählen zu können darüber hinaus also
fahren wir auch noch mit also den vier
ländern nicht eben beschrieben habe und
dort wurde uns eben stoff möglicherweise
auch sehr kurzfristig zur verfügung
stehen der dann mit dem hit mit hilfe
der bundeswehr erfurt wurde
dann habe ich noch mehr heim grill auf
der liste
ihr haus hat am montag eine andere liste
veröffentlicht er zufolge im november
3 millionen dosen sonntag nicht verletzt
worden sind ausgeliefert oder nicht zur
jüngsten und 16 millionen dosen moderner
ausgeliefert und nichts gibt diese dosen
ort
also was ich hier jetzt vorgetragen habe
das ist auch mal zu wiederholen ist
wie folgt zu beschreiben wir haben also
die noch also drei millionen biotec
dosen zur verfügung insgesamt
dritte lager ja ja natürlich also nicht
wir haben wir lagern also den impfstoff
nicht also in der in der friedrichstraße
sondern in quakenbrück lagerte im stoff
und dort haben wir noch drei millionen
also dosen zur verfügung
und das da damit wurde ich hart
konfrontiert und die verteile ich halt
schlicht jetzt nach dem schema 1,2
millionen
die woche bis weihnachten dann 08 in der
woche weihnachten bis neujahr und dann
noch mal 1,2 millionen erste januarwoche
und moderner waren noch zehn millionen
verfügbar und von moderner sind etwas
weniger abgerufen als wir noch haben wer
also aus dem aus dem kopf berechnet
hätten haben wir wahrscheinlich noch
etwa 23 millionen moderner da das müsste
ich aber prüfen dass billig nicht zu
zitieren weil ich das jetzt nicht also
vorbereitet auswendig habe aber das ist
ungefähr die im stoff lage die wir
derzeit also
mit der wir derzeit arbeiten müssen
eine nachfrage noch uns war ja bekannt
dass die staatsanwaltschaft münchen auch
dem verdacht nachgeht dass
schmiergeldzahlungen bei der beschaffung
von emigs masken also sehr teuren masken
geleistet worden sind planen sie ja ich
auch eine inventur was die ganzen masken
deals im gesundheitsministerium
angelangt
ich glaube dass wir die also
die situation bei den masken geschäften
insbesondere emigs nicht so belassen
können das ist das unter das also
hört das vertrauen
in die redlichkeit unserer beschaffung
aus und kann nicht so stehen haben somit
ist es so richtig dass also hier auch
präzise nachgeprüft werden muss was
stattgefunden hat und ich bin einfach um
verständnis dass ich in der in
anbetracht der problematischen also aus
meiner subjektiven sicht also
problematischen situation beim impfstoff
dass ich da den schwerpunkt gelegt habe
aber eh nix machen geschäfte sind sehr
bedeute sehr bedeutsam und das können
wir nicht einfach jetzt unter den tisch
fallen lassen sondern das muss auch noch
ganz genau geprüft werden was dort
stattgefunden hat
und noch mal
eine frage an herrn markus prüfen sie
haben sie auf dem den willen der eltern
den impfstellen der eltern auch gezielt
jetzt gibt es auch eltern die haben
vierjährige kinder dreijährige kinder
die die auch gerne im verlassen möchten
weil sie angst haben weil sie sorgen
haben und es gibt tatsächlich auch ärzte
die auch solche kinder schon impfen wir
haben eine frage wie bewerten sie diese
praxis und g
am 7 überblick wann möglicherweise mit
einer zulassung für diese altersgruppe
auch zu rechnen wäre
vielen dank dass eine sehr wichtige
frage wir können das nicht empfehlen zum
aktuellen zeitpunkt kinder unter fünf
jahren zu impfen es handelt sich nicht
nur um einen nicht zugelassenen
impfstoff sondern wir wissen auch nicht
ob die richtige dosis verkauft wird
sehen sie wir hatten das ja bei den 12
bis 17 jährigen als wir die dieses
hatten die der erwachsenendosis
entsprach und haben dann gesehen eben
bei den fünf- bis elfjährigen
haben wir nur ein drittel dieser dosis
und wir brauchen auch eine andere
darreichungsform deswegen kann ich allen
eltern nur davon abraten den off label
use hier anzuwenden und auch den
behandelnden kollegen im hinblick auf
die
daten das ist natürlich sehr stark davon
abhängig wann die firmen die
zulassungsdaten
vorlegen die protokolle haben wir schon
vor einigen monaten gesehen sie sehen
ähnlich aus wie die protokolle für die
fünf- bis elfjährigen und wir hoffen
sehr dass in den nächsten 12 monaten
hierzu auch dann bei den entsprechenden
zulassungsbehörden anträge vorgelegt
werden können
dann habe ich als letzte frage nach
einer online frage von frank stand table
herr lauterbach wie schauen sie auch die
unterschiedlich lange im zertifikat
laufzeit beziehungsweise auf die
unterschiedlich langen im zertifikat
laufzeiten in den eu mitgliedstaaten
sollte die eu das einheitlich reden ja
das ist definitiv meine auffassung
zum die laufzeit die zärtlichkeit
laufzeiten sollten vereinheitlicht
werden und das heute auf der grundlage
der neuesten wissenschaftlichen
erkenntnisse sollte stattfinden wahrheit
ich war es wird allerdings auch auf
eu-ebene heute darüber fahren ich bitte
um verständnis dass ich heute wenig
online fragen mit reingenommen habe das
tue hat sich hier nämlich aufgehangen
gehabt ohne dass ich das bemerkt hatte
das tut mir jetzt leid aber lässt sich
leider nicht ändern ich sage ja erstmal
vielen herzlichen dank für den besuch
heute nachmittag
ja so als die bundespressekonferenz die
erste bundespressekonferenz für den
neuen bundesgesundheitsminister karl
lauterbach zusammen mit dem chef des
robert-koch-instituts lothar wieler und
dem kinder- und jugendmediziner
professor durchaus köln ja wir haben
viel gehört über viele themen wir wollen
das ganze analysieren und vor allen
dingen natürlich auch ihre fragen
beantworten das machen wir zusammen
weiterhin mit unseren gästen professor
werner und christiane gotte schön dass
sie diese pressekonferenz sie lange auch
mitverfolgt haben bekommen sofort wieder
auf unser thema sozusagen
kinderimpfungen ich muss sie aber
professor werner weil sie ja auch
mitglied in diesem corona expertenrat
sind einfach mal fragen wir haben sehr
viel natürlich jetzt auch hier gehört
fragen und antworten zu dem ganzen hin
und her beim thema impfstoff beschaffung
was sagen sie denn dazu
also ich kann das nicht kommentieren
die impfstoff beschaffung ist sicher ein
schwieriges geschäft für den
bundesgesundheitsminister
ich habe die ausführungen verfolgt zur
kenntnis genommen es ist schwierig es
scheint schwierig zu sein aber mehr kann
ich dazu im moment auch nicht sagen der
die kristallkugel hatte eben keiner und
carlotta war hat eine ganze menge dazu
erklärt kommen wir aber wieder auf unser
thema das thema das impfen der kinder
ist hat jede menge kommentare und vor
allen dingen fragen gegeben ich fasse
mal einige zusammen roberto maldonado
schreibt über youtube kinderimpfungen
ohne langzeitstudien mit bedingten
zulassung sind absolut unverantwortlich
aber gleich dagegen hält jasmin warum
über youtube werden für impfungen
überhaupt langzeitstudien benötigt sie
gehören doch zu medikamenten die
dauerhaft eingenommen werden meine
kinder werden niemals geimpft gibt es
nicht schreibt denise lemke über youtube
katja thomas über facebook antwortet
viele verantwortungsbewusste menschen
werden ihre kinder trotzdem bereits
impfen lassen womöglich herr berner was
sagen sie dazu da ist weiterhin ist das
sozusagen der querschnitt durch die
elternschaft
ja ich glaube die meinungen sind sehr
unterschiedlich natürlich das ist ein
sehr emotionales thema kroner überhaupt
gewonnen
dann eine impfung von der wir alle noch
nicht viel wissen das ist kontrovers und
ich kann auch alle eltern verstehen die
die eine oder die andere meinung
vertreten die stiko und wir als
wissenschaftliche fachgesellschaft und
auch als experten so zu sagen wir können
uns nur auf das beziehen was wir an
vorhandenen daten haben was sie auch an
erfahrung haben und wie gesagt die
diskussion ist emotional man kann viele
dinge natürlich auch heute nicht
beantworten wir kennen diese impfstoffe
nicht nicht lange bei den kindern hat
man gerade begonnen zu impfen das muss
alles sorgfältig beobachtet werden
trotzdem bleibt natürlich die
einschätzung im einzelfall wie hoch ist
die sorge der eltern das kind ist
vielleicht selbst vor der erkrankung das
muss berücksichtigt und besprochen
werden mit dem kinderarzt und dann muss
eine gemeinsame entscheidung getroffen
werden wie übrigens aber auch bei vielen
anderen impfstoffen
ihr kollege eben aus diesem gremium hat
das ja ausführlich noch mal erklärt er
sagt zumindest klar bei den 12 bis 17
jährigen sei die nutzen-risiko-abwägung
klar unbedingt impfen bei den fünf- bis
elfjährigen hat er eben gesagt drei
kategorien kinder mit chronischen
erkrankungen dar sagt er eben unbedingt
kinder die im haushalts- leben mit
wohlhabenden personen auch bei kindern
die gesund sind und die eltern sagen ich
möchte es sagt ja eigentlich grünes
licht können sie das so auch
nachvollziehen
ja ich meine das ist genau die
empfehlung die die stiko gegeben hat und
die wir auch so auch unterstützen das
gibt die kinder mit vorerkrankungen wo
wir einfach ein risiko unterstellen dass
das erhöht ist und dass wir da annehmen
dass die impfung für diese gruppe
besonders wichtig ist und deswegen sagt
die stiko jahr für diese gruppe soll
excel geimpft werden und dann gibt es
die gruppe wo es risikogruppen in der
familie gibt und da ist ja das haben wir
über die letzten monate hier vielfach
erlebt und gehört da gibt es angst in
diesen familien und wenn diese angst vor
herrscht dann ist auch für diese kinder
natürlich die impfung empfohlen und an
sonst gibt es eben die vielen familien
die sich unsicher sind und da muss
abgewogen werden beraten werden
besprochen werden mit dem kinderarzt der
rat gesucht werden und daneben eine
entscheidung auch getroffen werden ich
glaube und das ist ja die diskussion die
wir unter den meinungen der eltern
gehört haben dass da gibt es kein ja
oder ein nein ein klares sondern das
muss im einzelfall überlegt werden
forderte jeder der ein kind hat was zur
schule geht und wo die schule
geschlossen worden ist wo ist
homeschooling gab die internet plattform
abgestimmt sind und und und alles in der
vergangenheit wird natürlich sagen im
von hin und her für mich ist schon
wichtig dass die schule offen bleibt und
was ansonsten alles versäumte diese
diskussion gibt es auch bei uns hier
christian karas schreibe youtube ich
hoffe die ansprache über die situation
der kinder manifestiert sich endlich der
öffentlichkeit kinder impfen ja aber
bitte nicht weiter isolieren und vor
allem dinge nicht die schulen schließen
und teil von kirow schreibt schule bitte
schließen also genau das gegenteil das
ist nicht mehr zu stoppen ständig gibt
es positive fälle in der schule ist das
auch wieder etwas was sie aus der
elternschaft kennen das die einen am
verzweifeln sind wegen der vielen corona
fälle und die anderen sind verzweifelt
weil die schule vielleicht droht zu
schließen oder klassen in quarantäne
geschickt werden
also definitiv da gehen in unseren
gremien natürlich die meinungen weit
auseinander da gibt es die 1 die halt
sagen die schulen müssen unbedingt offen
bleiben und die meisten landesverbände
die bei uns eben im bundeselternrat sind
die unterstützen das auch dass die
schulen flächendeckend offen bleiben
sollen wir als bundeselternrat
unterstützen das natürlich auch und dann
gibt es natürlich die eltern die sagen
um gottes willen wie sie es gerade in
der in diesem winter zuschrift da
vorgetragen haben und gottes willen
schließt die schulen das ist nicht mehr
aufzuhalten also die meinungen gehen von
da bis da und wir sammeln diese
meinungen natürlich auch die ängste und
die sorgen und versuchen daneben
natürlich auch mit den verantwortlichen
mit der politik darüber zu reden
jetzt haben wir anfangs ja bereits
gesagt in dieser woche montag ist
sozusagen offiziell der startschuss für
die impfkampagne gewesen der impfstoff
ist ausgeliefert worden und die fünf-
bis elfjährigen konnten sich sind schon
sehr viele in dieser woche geimpft
worden und natürlich haben wir viele
reporterinnen und reporter gehabt die am
montag beim start dieser impfkampagne
sich auch um gehört haben und das sind
die meinungen die wir da gehört haben
also ich bin ganz aufgeregt und
dies
selbst kämpfen
weil
weil ich keine kinder ich will mich halt
immer dass ich mehr freiheiten große
bruder ist schon gehen und wir haben
euch die ganze zeit darauf gewartet dass
er dann dass wir komplett in räumlicher
dass ich den großen für uns entschieden
war es für ihn entschieden weil es war
komisch den einen gang setzen zu lassen
werner da hört man erst mal positive
stimmen sozusagen die hoffnung man
gewinnt neue freiheiten jetzt muss man
ja erst mal fragen oder eine frage
stellt sich ja auch nikon ist in der
pressekonferenz wichtig gewesen herr
wieder sagt auch mit rund 40 durchsetzen
steht vor der haustür und man weiß noch
nicht so viel darüber aber wenn es
ansteckender ist ist es natürlich auch
eine gewisse gefahr was bedeutet das
denn jetzt eigentlich bei den kindern
wenn die jetzt gerade ihre erste impfung
bekommen und wir umgekehrt als
erwachsene gesagt bekommen boostern also
die dritte impfung und die schützt dann
vielleicht mit 70 80 prozent gegen
omikron wie sieht das denn bei den
kindern aus wenn omikron vor der haustür
steht
also ich glaube da muss man ganz klar
sagen die impfung der kinder die jetzt
anläuft die wird gegen die anrollende
omikron welle kein hindernis darstellen
bis bei den kindern einen impfschutz
aufgebaut sein kann und wir sprechen ja
auch mal noch darüber dass wir im moment
2,4 millionen impfdosen geliefert
bekommen haben oder zur verfügung stehen
ob die ausgeliefert sind weiß ich gar
nicht dass das nicht aus überhaupt nicht
ausreichend sein würde für eine größere
zahl von kindern oft und man muss ganz
klar sagen einen impfschutz und eine
immunantwort die ausreichend wäre um
eine omikron infektion zu verhindern
wird mit dieser impfung bei den kindern
in dieser altersgruppe nicht zu
erreichen seien im moment
also das heißt eine frage die auch
gekommen ist inwiefern wie wichtig ist
die kinder impfung jetzt für die
eindämmung der pandemie
in klammern omikron wird der nächste
vorherrschende variante sein da sind sie
skeptisch dass jetzt diese
kinderimpfungen speziell da eine rolle
spielen oder
wir haben wir gerade auch aus der
bundespressekonferenz gehört dass herr
wähler davon ausgeht dass diese welle in
den nächsten wochen deutschland erreicht
und bald auch die dominierende variante
sein wird und da das ist da muss man
keinen mediziner sein um sich ausrechnen
zu können dass die impfkampagne bei den
kindern die jetzt anläuft nicht dazu
ausreichend wird oder überhaupt keinen
beitrag dazu leisten kann sozusagen
diese mikrowelle
aufzuhalten das ist einfach nicht
möglich das dauert zu lange der
impfschutz ist erst nach wochen
aufgebaut so dass wir damit keinen
effekt haben werden also verstehe ich
sie richtig schließen sie sich auch in
dem aufruf sozusagen an dass die
erwachsenen so schnell wie möglich sich
boostern lassen sollten um sozusagen den
schutz in der familie zu liefern
also definitiv das ist immer unsere
haltung gewesen wir brauchen die impfung
der erwachsenen vollständigen impfschutz
die booster im vorhinein wenn es
angemessen ist und jetzt vor der omicron
variante nach allem was wir wissen
brauchen wir den dritten die dritte
impfung bei den erwachsenen das ist das
entscheidende das wird eine rolle
spielen für die verhinderung von
schweren infektionsfällen die also
ohnehin nur der gruppe der erwachsenen
erreicht im wesentlichen es gibt ganz
wenige ausnahmen pilgern so dass wenn
wir einfluss nehmen wollen dann kann das
nur über die booster impfung und die
erhöhung der ihn fragten bei den
erwachsenen gehen die kinder werden
dafür die pandemie keine rolle spielen
frau geht er jetzt haben wir aber
gemeinsam jahr die netten stimmen auch
der kinder gehört ich möchte geimpft
werden ich will wieder alles machen
können etc
was haben sie denn für ein gefühl was
hören sie ist das für die kinder
vielleicht auch eher eine psychologische
sache dass es den kindern hilft ich kann
in die schule gehen ich bin geimpft und
viel weniger die sorge vor dem schweren
verlauf mit
sicherheit also da gibt es wir hören ja
die kinder meinungen über die eltern und
da gibt es kinder die sich gerne impfen
lassen wollen weil die dann sagen ich
bin beschützt ich kann die schule gehen
ich kann viel weniger am brand stecken
und dem gar sehr positiv gegenüber
stehen aber das kommt natürlich auch
darauf an wie das in den elternhäusern
diskutiert wird im vorfeld ob da eine
ablehnende oder eben offene der
aufgeschlossenheit der beiden kindern
halt da ist
jetzt erinnere ich mich an einen beitrag
da wurde auch mal ein vater interviewt
dessen kind gerade geimpft worden ist
und er sagte na ja was haben wir machen
entweder das kind kriegt die antikörper
durch die impfung oder durch corona nach
dem motto dann werden sich sowieso hier
alle anstecken ist da so ein bisschen
auch die haltung der eltern dass der
eine sagt okay ich bin für mein kind
ansonsten fängt es sich halt corona ein
das ist kaum zu verhindern
jetzt würde ich so nicht unterschreiben
die eltern machen sich da schon gedanken
darüber und da gibt es wie gesagt
mittelfeld das ist unentschlossen das
wartet die nächsten ergebnisse ab und
schaut wie die empfehlungen weiterlaufen
hört auf den kinderarzt und überlegt
sich das dann noch mal in der familie
schaut eben das neue zahlen kommen rein
wie sicher ist die impfung wir sind die
nebenwirkungen und so und dann
entscheiden die dann danach und da denke
ich da wird es eine menge eltern geben
die sich dann auch für die impfung
entscheiden werden wenn die
nebenwirkungen wirklich so gering sind
aber das wissen wir jetzt in dem moment
noch nicht das haben wir nur dann gibt
es die eltern sie sagen dem kommt nicht
in frage also mein kind ist doch kein
versuchskaninchen also das hätte ich
nicht unterstützen und dann gibt es
natürlich die eltern die sagen ja klar
natürlich dass ich mein kind also wie
gesagt wir haben die gesamte bandbreite
natürlich auch unter den eltern und die
kinder meinungen sind natürlich vom
elternhaus geprägt das kann man nicht
anders sagen
jetzt haben wir herr professor werner ja
in der bundespressekonferenz auch noch
mal fragen gehört an den
bundesgesundheitsminister was die
impfpflicht angeht ob sie kommen kann
wenn ausreichend impfstoff da ist sie
selbst waren am anfang ein bisschen
skeptisch noch vor wenigen wochen ob es
wirklich eine impfpflicht geben soll wie
stehen sie denn heute dazu
also ich bin nach wie vor skeptisch was
das thema impfpflicht angeht ich finde
die diskussion darüber ist wichtig die
muss geführt werden die muss auch
öffentlich geführt werden herr minister
hat ja auch ausgeführt die entscheidung
wird dann eine gewissensentscheidung im
parlament sein ich persönlich kann ganz
klar sagen ich bin nicht für eine
impfpflicht weil ich glaube es muss
alles ausgeschöpft werden an
möglichkeiten einer erfolgreichen
impfkampagne also an niederschwelligen
angeboten der impfstoff muss zur
verfügung stellen das haben wir auch
gehört zur verfügung stehen wir müssen
alles tun um die leute zu überzeugen
dass die impfung nicht für sie selbst
alleine sondern eben auch für die
anderen die eben vielleicht krank sind
die eine schwäche haben im immunsystem
oder eine krebserkrankung der spd
schützen können ich persönlich glaube
die impfpflicht wird eine polarisierung
in der gesellschaft
verstärken die es ohnehin schon gibt das
wird der gesellschaft nicht gut tun und
das hat dieses virus auch nicht verdient
dass wir ihm damit sozusagen doch den
gefallen tun die gesellschaft weiter zu
spalten also sie bleiben bei der linie
lieber überzeugen und vielleicht gründe
präsentieren dann direkt die frage an
sie nochmal raum schreibt wie youtube
und fragt vielleicht wäre es gut auch
nochmal etwas über die quoten des teams
und des syndroms bei kindern zu hören
gibt es noch mehr bekannte corona
spätfolgen bei kindern also ganz
sachlich darüber sprechen was wäre denn
sozusagen die gründe für impfungen bei
kindern wie sieht es denn aus mit den
langzeitfolgen
das ist eine wichtige frage dass der
provisorische hat das ja in der
bundespressekonferenz auch gesagt die
stiko hat in ihren beratungen die system
hat bis also eine schwere entzündung
fieber reaktion des körpers nach einer
durchgemachten corona virusinfektion
vier wochen danach das ist einer der
gründe gewesen warum man gesagt hat die
verhinderung dieses syndroms ist eine
der rechtfertigungen für eine allgemeine
impfempfehlung letztlich bei dieser
altersgruppe 12 bis 17 jahren wir wissen
dass diese in diese komplikationen in
einer größenordnung von 1 zu 5.000 1 zu
10.000 oder noch etwas seltener auftritt
wir beobachten jetzt das kann man nicht
abschließend beurteilen bei der delta
variante
dass das camp syndrom seltener auftritt
möglicherweise bei omikron kann man
natürlich gar nicht beurteilen im moment
die schweren verläufe haben wir bei den
12 bis 17 jährigen in der altersgruppe
fünf bis elf jahre ist es ein beweggrund
bewegend gewesen für die stiko zu sagen
ja wir bieten diese impfung auch an
aber es ist sicher in dieser
altersgruppe ein kleineres problem als
bei den 12 bis 17 jährigen was das
lankowitz sozusagen also diese
folgeerkrankung angeht haben wir wenig
verlässliche daten bisher wir sehen
dieses problem vielleicht noch mehr in
der altersgruppe eben der älteren
jugendlichen in der altersgruppe team
über die wir jetzt reden die fünf- bis
elfjährigen spiel aus meiner sicht bis
auf wenige einzelfälle das longo wird
kein der entscheidend große rolle
tja frage ob das sind natürlich
antworten die es daneben für die eltern
auch schwierig macht das ganz genau zu
entscheiden sie haben allerdings schon
eine sache angeschnitten vor der
bundespressekonferenz erinnerlich sie
haben gesagt da ist natürlich keine
tolle sache wenn der herr mertens also
der chef der stiko selbst sagt ja ich
würde mein kind nicht impfen lassen dann
hörst du horcht man natürlich als
elternteil auf umgekehrt hat die neue
bundesfamilienministerin nun in einem
interview sehr deutlich gemacht dass sie
ihre kinder doch impfen lassen würde und
eigentlich sollte das jeder machen ist
das so eine sache wenn solche meinungen
kommen erhöht das den druck macht das
schwieriger daneben für eltern irgendwie
entscheidungen zu treffen
ja natürlich also diese
widersprüchlichen aussagen die für
unseren verunsichern eltern sehr sehr
sehr stark
wir haben die diskussionen natürlich
entfacht und das ist ja sowieso schon
hoch emotionales thema
widersprüchliche aussagen von der
politik kommen und von
der darüber dann eben auch aussagen
trifft nach denen sich die eltern ja
auch richten wollen das wird definitiv
zu verschaffen
die verunsicherung ist das eine was die
eltern auch was dann ja
selbstverständlich werden auch ja
ja ich würde das gerne insofern noch
kommentieren ich glaube herr mertens ist
in dieser aussage auch ein bisschen
falsch zitiert worden oder bzw nicht
vollständig zitiert worden er hat gesagt
zum damaligen zeitpunkt des interviews
gibt es noch keine stiko empfehlung und
wenn noch keine stiko empfehlung
vorliegt würde er auch sein
siebenjähriges kind im moment nicht
impfen lassen und diese aussage kann ich
aus meiner sicht auch nur unterstützen
er hat nicht gesagt in dieser klarheit
wie es dann letztlich kommuniziert
worden ist er würde sein kind nicht
impfen lassen sondern zur damaligen zeit
hat das nicht impfen lassen wollen
verstehe die korrektur von ihnen richtig
wenn die stiko also sozusagen die
empfehlung ausspricht dann würde er sich
dem vielleicht anschließend ist
natürlich auch das problem was man hier
hört was man da hört wenn vielleicht
auch etwas nicht vollständig zitiert ist
aber natürlich frau gottes sie haben
recht das sorgt natürlich dann für
diskussionen wir haben bei den o-tönen
der kinder die da nun gesprochen haben
ja auch gerade gehört ja dann kann ich
das und das wieder machen
t punkt ahlers schreibt über youtube ist
es nicht fragwürdig kinder zu impfen
hauptsächlich um soziale ausgrenzung zu
vermeiden frau gottes
ja aber die soziale also wir reden mehr
über schule und die kinder sind ja in
den logs zeiten tatsächlich auch
isoliert gewesen und da gibt es ja auch
psychologen die sich jetzt mit den
folgen beschäftigen und das wichtigste
es eigentlich dass dich das die schulen
geöffnet bleiben kann und alles was wir
dazu tun können und daher appelliere ich
auch an die erwachsenen machen weil das
ist eine große diskussion die bei uns
ausgebrochen ist warum kinder sich im zu
lassen müssen weil es so viele
unvernünftige erwachsenen und da kann
ich nur oder probiert und auch der
bundeselternrat an die erwachsenen bitte
sich impfen zu lassen dass eben die
kinder die sowieso schon die
leidtragenden dieser pandemie sind
insgesamt aber im besonderen die kinder
das reine vernunft auch um sich greift
das die erwachsenen sich eben zu lassen
weil dann würde es auch nicht zu diesen
zu schließungen kommen die
von varianten vielleicht befürchten muss
das ist eben das problem dass einerseits
ist vielleicht wunderbar ist wenn heute
der bundesgesundheitsminister sagt wir
sind wirklich die schnellsten was das
boostern angeht in europa 1,5 millionen
gestern aber man muss natürlich kritisch
merken dass werden dann wohl diejenigen
sein die round about 70 doppelt
geimpften die dann sagen okay impfen ist
gut schnell boostern und dann werden wir
wahrscheinlich wieder das problem haben
dass es eben doch einen grossen
prozentzahl von erwachsenen gibt die
eben sich nicht impfen lassen aber sie
sagen eben professor werner da muss man
mit argumenten überzeugen keine
impfpflicht bleibt trotzdem die frage
was man heute mitte dezember eben noch
an appellen noch an überzeugungen noch
an fakten für erwachsene eben liefern
soll
ja ich denke das argument das von gott
gesagt hat nämlich dass die kitas die
erwachsenen und ich glaube da hat sie
absolut recht nach 20 monaten pandemie
den kindern auch etwas schuldig sind
nämlich dass sie wieder in die schule
oder dass sie in die schule gehen können
dass die schulen offen bleiben das wird
daran hängen und ausschließlich daran
hängen ob die erwachsenen ausreichend
geimpft sind ob und ob wir die schweren
verläufe bei den erwachsenen verhindern
können wir müssen nicht die kinder die
schweren infektionen bei den kindern
verhindern die sind zu selten wir müssen
verhindern dass die erwachsenen schwer
krank werden und das ist die aufgabe
primär der erwachsenen und wir haben sie
in der bundespressekonferenz deutlich
gehört es sind weniger die schulen wo
die kinder sich anstecken sondern im
urlaub in der familie et cetera und die
schulen helfen sogar das war zumindest
ja ein ergebnis heute das ganze wieder
zu kontrollieren durch testungen in der
schule das ganze wieder instanzen wieder
runter zu bekommen ganz zum schluss
fragte was wünschen sie sich was fordern
sie herr berner hat es gerade schon
formuliert was er sich wünschen würde
was sagen sie als vorsitzende des
elternrates
wir wünschen uns dass die gesellschaft
mehr auf die familien und die kinder
achtet
dass wir die schulen schlechten deckend
offenhalten können dass eine sichere
bestimmungen gewährleistet werden